Machine translation has a relatively short
history. It’s only been going for 50 years
or so and it has entered really quite a new
phase in the last 10, 15 years....I think
it’s an absolute miracle that linguists
and computer engineers and other very clever
people can now make and have for some time
been able to make machines simulate human
speech with these automatic answering things
on the telephone. I think it’s a miracle
that they have been able to make machines
decode human speech and produce written transcript
of it automatically. These incidentally
are two key features that are used and will
always be used in machines that simulate speech
translation. There are some devices on the
market already that do that and of course
the way they do it is by effectively transcribing
the speech in the source language into text
and putting that text through a translation
device, taking the text in the target language
and then sounding it out just like your telephone
answering device does.
So it’s not actually speech to speech.It’s
really tertiary speech.It’s speech as
the product of a program that takes text as
input and that text is translated from something
that has transformed speech into text in the
first place.Okay, so it’s a structure
like that.
But the real thing is this.There is science
and then there is engineering.Translation
machines both written and spoken, but the
spoken is a purely derivative thing from the
written, are extremely clever and give us
a lot reasons for thought about what language
is and how we may understand language better,
but the way they work bears little resemblance,
in fact, no resemblance at all to the way
human beings both speak, use language and
translate between languages and that’s fine.That’s
what engineering if for.I mean the way
airplanes fly resembles not at all the way
birds fly.It doesn’t have to.What
you want is the flight, but for that reason
my personal view is that machine translation
always requires the existence of human translators
to feed of and that is how it works.It
uses existing translations done by humans
and computes the most probable match from
the vast amount of paired texts that exist
on the web.
Secondly, machine translation both of speech
and of text will expand people’s general
expectation of the availability of communication
between languages and far from putting translators
out of a job it will support the extension
of translation as a major professional and
a central part of global civilization.So
the other question is what are the technical
blocks in the way of improving the quality
of machine translation?That I think you
really have to ask a computer scientist because
they are very technical and I'm not part of
the team trying to solve such things, but
the overall picture is this.The more machine
translation there is the more translation
will happen, the more people will expect to
be able to communicate with other folk and
the more they will realize that although machines
can clear the ground the actual translation
has to be done by somebody because language
is human behavior.It’s machine simulated,
but they’re not doing anything like what
a human translator is doing.